TODD KERPELMAN: So if
you've been playing around
with Google's new
sign-in library,
you might have a few
follow-up questions,
like can you use
this to identify
the user to your server?
How do you use it to authorize
services like Google Drive?
And what's up with this
disconnect call anyway?
And why did I choose to
represent our developer
as a delicious little
green gummy person?
Well, let's see if we can answer
some of these questions for you
in this episode of "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, there.
I'm Todd Kerpelman, and let's
get into a little Google
sign-in Q&A, shall we?
All right, we'll start
with a simple one.
Question number one-- how can
I tell if my user has actually
signed in?
Well, this one's
pretty straightforward.
Just check and see if
the GIDsignin.shared
instance.currentuserobject
exists.
If it does, then, yes, your
user has signed in, and if it
doesn't, then, no, they haven't.
OK, that was kind of
a warm-up question.
Let's move on to something
a little more complicated.
Question number two-- can I use
the new Google sign-in library
for things like
authorizing my app
to use other Google
services like Google Drive?
The answer is yes, in
fact, you probably should.
The new Google sign-in
library still uses OAuth 2.0.
Meaning that you can use to
not only identify the user,
but your user can also use
it to authorize your app
to use a number of
different Google services
on their behalf.
How you do this depends a bit
on the other Google libraries
you're using, but for
many of these libraries
you're going to need
to do two things.
First, add the scopes
you're requesting
to the scopes array that's part
of the Google sign-in singleton
instance.
You can request things
like seeing what files are
in your user's
Google Drive folder,
asking for their Google+
profile information,
viewing what events are on their
calendar, and much, much more.
Now after a user has
signed in, you'll
need to pass their OAuth
information to the library
that you are using.
In Google Drive's case, you can
grab your OAuth 2 authorizer
by calling
authentication.fetcherauthorizer
on your current user, and then
pass that along to your Google
Drive service, kind of like so.
At this point, your
Google Drive library
is now properly
authorized, and you
can use it to access
your user's drive folder,
list files there, or do whatever
else your user has given you
permission to do.
I like "ALF."
Don't judge.
Question number three-- how do I
send my user's ID to my server?
So once a user is
signed into Google,
you get back their
user ID, which
you're free to use on the
client to identify them.
Now, you might
think that you could
use this ID to send information
about your user to the server.
But, in fact, this would
be a terrible idea.
The issue is that you should
never trust your client.
An evil-doer could very
easily hack your client
or create a fake client to
send down a similar request,
but use somebody else's user ID.
Now if your server were to
trust that user ID blindly,
you could end up leaking a whole
bunch of sensitive information.
That's bad.
So instead, you'll notice that
in addition to the user ID,
Google sign-in also provides
this giant string known
as an ID token.
This giant string, which
really looks more like this,
contains three sections.
You've got a small header,
some data about the user, which
includes things
like your user's ID,
this application that
this ID token is for,
and a signature provided
by Google servers.
You can basically
think of this signature
as a hash that confirms that
everything in the data portion
here is accurate.
If an evil hacker tried
to change this data,
the signature wouldn't match up,
and the token would be invalid.
So here's how this would work.
Your app would send this ID
token down to your server.
Your server would then verify
that this ID token looks legit,
and there are two
ways of doing this.
You can pass it along
to Google to verify
for you, which is easy to
do, but takes a bit of time,
because it involves
a network call,
or you can verify it yourself
on your own servers, which
is a whole lot faster, but
requires a little more code.
Luckily we have libraries
for you to do this,
and I recommend you use them.
Don't try and reinvent the
wheel yourself, particularly
where security is involved.
Either way, once you've verified
that this ID token is, in fact,
legit, and it's
intended for your app,
and it was issued
somewhat recently,
you can then extract the
user's ID from this ID token
and feel confident that
your user is really
who they say they are.
Now, at this point, I'd probably
have your server generate
its own random string to
send back to your client,
and maybe you can use that as
a way to identify your user,
rather than verifying this
ID token every single call.
But, you know, it's up to you.
Question number four--
what's up with these access
token methods?
So, if you've been perusing our
reference documentation, which
is how I like to spend
my Friday nights,
you might notice we have
some methods like these.
What are they, and when
do you need to use them?
Well, the short answer is
almost never these days.
Back before you could easily get
this fetcher authorizer object
to do things like enable
the Google Drive service,
like I talked about
in question two,
you might have used these
calls to manually authorize
the Google Drive
service on your own.
But now you don't even
need them for that anymore.
So the best answer is don't
worry about these calls.
Much like job titles
at a start-up company,
they're not necessarily as
important as they sound.
Hm, hey, can we amp
that up a little bit?
Mm, a little bit more, more--
oh, yeah, that's the stuff.
That's good.
I like that.
Question number five-- what's
the difference between sign-out
and disconnect?
So in the previous
video, you saw
me sign the user out by
calling GIDsignin.shared
instance.signout, right?
Now, this call basically removes
all locally stored information
that Google has about
this user's identity.
The sign-in library
simply doesn't know
anything about them anymore.
This is nearly instantaneous.
It's all just local data.
No network calls are needed,
so there's no call back.
So right after
calling it, you're
probably going to want to do
your own purging of locally
stored information
associated with that account.
But then if you check
around our documentation,
you'll notice we have
a disconnect call along
with this did disconnect
with error delegate method.
So what are those all about?
Well, the idea
with disconnect is
there are times your user wants
to stay signed into your app,
but they no longer want
their Google identity
associated with that account.
A typical situation might be
where you've got [? Nap, ?]
where you're managing
sign-in some other way.
Maybe you have your
own account system,
but you're still using
Google sign-in so
that you can, for example, get
access to your user's Google
Drive content.
Well, this user might want
to say, hey, you know,
I'd like to stay
signed into your app.
I just don't want to give you
access to my Google account
anymore.
So we want to wipe out the
stuff associated with the Google
account.
And for that you're
going to want
to add a disconnect feature.
This is typically something
you might put in a My Account
screen somewhere.
So disconnect is
a way for a user
to break the ties between your
app and their Google account.
Calling disconnect does
involve a network call
to Google servers, so
there is a delegate method
that gets called on your client
when the process is finished.
Now, in this
callback, you're going
to want to remove any data that
was retrieved through Google's
APIs-- both locally,
as well as anything
that is stored on your servers.
Now disconnecting, it's not
particularly common case,
but it is important
to have, and so
that's why you see
it mentioned all
throughout the documentation.
But again, don't confuse
it with signing out.
They're two very
different things.
So there you have it,
some important questions
around the new Google sign-in
library answered for you.
If you have other questions
about the sign-in library,
well, you know, you can
go read the documentation.
That is what it's
there for, you know.
But you could also leave
them in the comments below
and maybe we will
take a look at them.
As always, thanks for watching,
and I will see you soon
on "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]